moi je voyage donc c'est le titre c'est
le titre de la chanson c'est aussi le
titre d'un album de soul aznavour donc
douze chansons sur le sujet je temporise
et une ambiance un peu walt disney dans
cette chanson je me trompe je ne sais
pas quand une bonne question ma question
pas ouais ouais moyens non si le
problème si tu peux éviter de les poser
quand je parle c'est tout d'accord mais
qui parle tout le temps même temps que
ça c'est vrai je suis dit alors que vous
savez que je suis là bien alors je
voyage alors je voyage c'est le titre
donc de la chanson avec katia c'est
aussi le titre du nouvel album de
charles aznavour donc douze chansons sur
vos sujets favoris la jeunesse la
société l'amour la nostalgie
une chanson qui s'appelle la critique
car vous dites on a beau dire au fond
que l'on s'en contre fout elle vous
détruit le moral et vous en fout un coup
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
j'en pense que j'en pense c'est que vous
qui avez jamais répondu c'est à vous
n'avez jamais abordé le problème de la
critique vous avez jamais répondu ni par
téléphone ni par courrier
vous avez toujours ignoré les critiques
et dieu sait si vous en avez eu je
trouve ça formidable que un jour comme
ça vous en vous en parliez en disant
plus la vérité c'est à dire non on s'en
fout mais en fait ça nous fait du mal
quoi puis-je est amusant de le faire
aujourd'hui pensent que vous êtes une
vache sacrée aujourd'hui à dire du
maintenant mais plus personne peut dire
du mal de vos charmes c'est sûr
lorsqu'un peuple à gérer mais j'avais
envie de faire non c'est bien parce que
c'est pas amer en plus vous dites c'est
vrai la critique on les écoute plus que
parfait mais une amertume vrai je sais
bien il ya une fois quand même où
c'était un peu chaud c'est quand vous
avez fait l'olympia en 55
il y avait un journaliste qui avait
écrit pourquoi ne pas chanter avec une
jambe de bois
c'est vraiment méchant donc là vous avez
exigé un droit de réponse et la seule
fois d'ailleurs sur radio luxembourg
vous aviez droit à trois minutes
finalement vous êtes resté neuf minutes
vous en trouviez plus la wii
1 d'autant plus je venais d'avoir un
accident alors là c'est moi j'aurais pu
la voir et me faisait beaucoup enduré
quand même au début avec votre physique
votre voix vos chansons ah j'avais tout
contre moi c'est vrai la voix les
chansons disais que c'était pas c'était
pas populaire c'est devenu préfet de
région 17 commercial est vrai oui c'est
vrai j'ai eu droit à tout un jour au
crazy horse et vous entendez quelqu'un
qui dit j'ai jamais entendu rien de bon
il était devant moi j'avais envie de
donner un coup de pied dans la figure
mais c'est pas dans mes habitudes il ya
un journal qui avait écrit maintenant on
laisse chanter les handicapés non mais
sérieux c'est des trucs maintenant on
relit plus ça dans les critiques n'ont
maintenant notamment michael wolf jantes
et justin et petrucciani a fait la
carrière concède empêchons et volé pour
le mettre sur huit charles sinon on va
se faire chier alors sur les avons le 22
mai 2004 vous fêterez vos 80 ans sur la
série palais des congrès ce sera la
réussite ou croyable je réussirai même
avoir 80 81 ans ont fait à peine 60 ha
par l'audition est alors donc le 22 mai
2004 dont vous aurez 80 ans sur scène ce
sera la dernière de vos représentations
qui commence le 16 avril je le dis à
jeudi à tout le monde parce qu'attention
lui sur scène ses trente chansons assez
un an à 80 avait pas de rappel pas de
rappel et 30 chansons s'ils veulent des
rappels je m'arrête à 25 mais je prends
la peine et la perte de temps alors il
est très secret à vous acharner ça vous
êtes très très très pudique j'étais
absolument une interview web parce que
c'est intéressant dans les journaux en
question
je lis suis jamais on a fait un petit
sondage sur luis suarez l'amour 67% des
français pensent que vous avez une
tortue 3 canaries une chatte par exemple
ces crevettes congelées g par un crayon
voilà une res % des français pensent que
vous êtes chauffeur de taxi à tobrouk
comme quoi vous devriez quand même
beaucoup plus loin les mouches ne me
trouveront à six wi grandes répliques 4%
des français trouvent que vous leur
faites penser à quelqu'un sans qu'ils
puissent retrouver le nom
et alors là 96% des français qui pensent
que vous portez les talonnettes
non j'ai failli alors pas besoin
non non de regarder la série bones en
entendrons c'est vrai terrien qui permet
chaque deviers joncour
voilà oui
j'ai cirer les pompes hallyday gémissant
souliers à charles a lâché ma fille et
mes pieds quand même investi les cheveux
donc je tiens à dire à vos amis
téléspectateurs qui vous connaissent mal
c'est pas une perruque à vous avez fait
d'un nouveau jeu les éléments non
récurrents
j'arrive de la cambe oui c'est ça elle
vient des 100 dollars mais de là ça
vachement bien marcher chef de bruit
mais la terre est bonne si vous avez les
cheveux un petit peu long en ce moment
c'est parce que vous allez faire un rôle
assez pas du tout pour faire le nom
c'est pas pour ça cool parce que le père
goriot votre nouveau né a été offert par
par piaf
vous racontez ça dans votre
autobiographie le temps d avant paru
chez flammarion et avec gréco c'est vrai
que ça a été les premiers mots je me
souviens vous faire refaire le nez on en
parlait à la maison c'est un événement
aujourd'hui tout le monde se fait
refaire le nez
non galabru l'a pas fait nancy 11
etienne est premier avec des coloris si
c'était assez scandaleux à l'époque en
même temps on bat mois on la pense eu
parce que j'étais inconnu
ouais donc on a fait les cheveux on a
fait le nez est alors le plus tu es
faisons l'habite
non ce que tu sais pas ce que tu sais
pas c'est que quand il était petit
charles aznavour avait les jambes
arquées oui déficience humaine c'est
l'arc et les genres si les jean louis
xiii voilà louis xiii et l'italie en
vacances c'est tragique de la paire qu à
berck non derrière webber
voilà non mais c'est une jolie plage
berck plage magnifique magnifique vous
avez survécu à tous à vous avez survécu
à la critique on l'a vu j'ai survécu à
la guerre parce que c'est vrai pendant
la guerre quand je vais partir on va
dire que j'ai survécu à dix ans non mais
c'est vrai quand vous étiez petit on
sérieusement vous étiez souvent par un
bon l'occupation il est souvent menée à
la kommandantur en vous prenez pour m
oui oui vous étiez emmené à la
kommandantur aider avec le nez que
j'avais mais je pensais pas pour un
français pur sang vous avez fait refaire
en 45 c'est trop tard oui vous avez
survécu d'abord à cause de ça ensuite
vos parents était sympathisant
communiste il riani avec ma notion de
ftp moyle affiche rouge des coups de
mains voila ca c'etait il venait chez
vous manouche ont ils vu vous apprenez
les échecs
oui venez chez nous et puis sa femme a
été cachée chez nous et ensuite c'est
les amis de longtemps voire avant ont
survécu à la kommandantur survécu à la
fréquentation de sueur est probable non
mais c'est vrai alors vous quitté
l'école à l'âge de 10 ans il ya 15 ans
fait du marché noir pour nourrir votre
famille parce que votre père étaient
étaient engagées dans des eaux plus
grande amie rageusement et là vous
vendez du chocolat des charcuteries et
des débats pour femmes
oui à qui veut les vendre aux autorités
allemandes
ils ont manqué à l'ouverture alors
j'allais aux portes de paris avec ma
petite sacoche comme ça et puis je
proposais mais baa aux allemands qui
voulaient absolument en acheter dans les
acheter je me souviens exactement du pij
monde et où c'est toujours 20 marques un
ordre d'occupation mais je partais vite
parce que dès qu'on pensait là
maintenant ça filait alors un jour il ya
un riche armenia qui décide de faire une
bourse comme ça pour aider
des petits arméniens les enfants démunis
vous vous retrouvez dans une école pour
apprendre la tsf
enfin ça vous ennuie énormément
évidemment centrale voilà le tsl
bruxelles une voie là et les rues de la
lune vous emmerdez vous sécher les cours
pour aller au cinéma l'après-midi au
music hall le sens où alors j'allais
aussi voir jean kissi avec des cours de
comédie gentil s'il était dans
l'assassin habite au 21
parce que j'allais dire je t'adore l'on
sait exactement je suis moi même je fais
des films
et alors en 1941 vous rencontrer pierre
roche si vous faites un duo qui
s'appelle roche et aznavour départ et
vous êtes embauché par tous voilà
c'était dans des boîtes de nuit
on a fait beaucoup de remplacements
aussi et en 45 votre première chanson
j'ai vu est interprété par georges ulmer
et à leurs montants la refuser cette
chanson ça c'est incroyable ça meurt à
la fin c'est intéressant ça quand même
vous vous êtes un jeune auteur
compositeur de chansons vous êtes en
face d'yves montand qui clament déjà une
star il vous dit moi je suis d'accord
pour chanter la chanson si à la fin il
meurt ou dit non non mais j'ai même eu
des des chanteurs très connus qui
voulaient y consigner les gens sont
jugés non j'ai mieux pas jamais donné la
moitié d'une une oeuvre à quelqu'un qui
n'a pas travaillé dessus
comme je n'ai jamais parce que je
changeais une ligne vous une phrase à
dans une chanson d'un dr camara je n'ai
jamais dit je signe avec pas joli vous
êtes bien vrai la classe j'ai placé la
classe et les montants a refusé à ça
c'est encore pire que tout je me voyais
déjà
oui en dix ans il ya jamais une chanson
sur le métier qu'à marcher c'est fou oui
mais là c'est excusable parce que la
plupart des gens pensent y ait la même
chose alors en 1946 francis blanche vous
présente
edith piaf c'était dans une émission de
francis blanche à que l'on a connu bien
mais c'est pas lui qui me l'a présenté
c'est elle qui elle vous a fait comme ça
comme salma fait comme dans la chanson à
la règle en pareil
et alors elle vous ouvre un petit peu
les portes de l'amérique vous allez vous
faites un coup boli vous décidez d'aller
chanter au carnegie hall à new york faut
le faire par importer personnes vous
louer un avion avec 150 journalistes
vous payez vous louez le carnegie hall
e3400 place vous chantez vous fait un
tabac évidemment après tout le monde il
a réussi au carnegie hall
donc le monde entier vous appelle qui
risque rien n'a rien tout ça c'est fort
eh oui
sans parler on devait en parler anglais
en lisant le texte un i la tête pas de
talonnettes mais la déco ils remettent
ça c'est que vous avez peur de la mort
ça ça dépend des jours où j'ai demandé
nuit exactement aujourd'hui ça va
aujourd'hui ça va très vite
pourquoi ils vous aurez droit à des
funérailles nationales non non non ou
alors en arménie a peut-être mais j
aurais pas la manger un cas vraiment
france on en mairie avec ledroit un mot
pour la voirie qui soutient les tous les
trois blessés
ah ben ali a bat andrea cavola montfort
l'amaury ainsi que vous connaissez le
lieu non c'est un cloître du 3ème siècle
ah oui pas n'importe quoi et puis en
face gg en marche à un peu plus loin
j'ai cessible j'ai marshall 1
il ya du monde chez nous à ces six
candidats oui et je suis mieux que j'ai
un fait construire ce qu'il fallait
d'ailleurs j'ai la folie de la
construction alors bien les besoins sont
sympas voisinage impasse que le
sculpteur ya des embrouilles après c'est
le bordel ils m'ont dit mes déchets